my daughter is gay my daughter is gay
but she's the girl thank God I don't
think I can do uh I don't think I can do
a stellar with titties look like me with
a bend down on you don't mind a gay
daughter she just has to be like a
feminine gay dog well I mean I tell my
daughter do what make you happy you eat
it I don't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she's 32 your thirty year old daughter
black don't crack but my knees hurt
[Laughter]
deteriorate so inside she's gay she's uh
and you know I it's been like being a
gay pair like I've been to prison for
trafficking cocaine no how many years in
the joint yes a year did that sound like
somebody like when Jim just asked you
that just now were you like oh you done
times I felt like I was on the you know
the lingo oh you've been to jail jail
sure that's just a porn he vouches okay
that's good to know Mike gonna do a
tribute to a great Jim jovial days and
now that's good you shouldn't give them
that joke make them pay for it for
Saturday why you mad at us for you for
getting your on a radio that is true why
you scolding me for helping you Denny's
[ __ ] yeah mic up yeah dipping your
[ __ ] dump thing into your tea he's
got a sugar rush and you're all [ __ ]
mad at us yeah corrected you oh you've
you jimjo buzz about the Sega's chip and
said people's SPD Jim do you think you
get raped in prison and he used to go
look at me I get raped in the bus on the
way to prison
that might be true Jim that's an old
joke but uh might mess up my daughter's
game but you know as a parent and I just
started really talking about this we
know our kids are gay honestly we do we
know from you you've been denied you try
to being denied but you have you have
look honestly and I tell this onstage my
mother-in-law told me she was very
Kristin and she said this baby got a
clean-looking spirit she was like five
years old when she told me that and I
was out [ __ ] you yeah we got a click
Nicky's beard she was so right she
called it out and my dad as my daughter
started to get older it's like everybody
else was trying to hit [ __ ] house but
her like I made a mistake and I this is
when I really knew she was gay yeah I
borrowed his book by gay author I cannot
think of the name of I heard it on the
radio and it was raving about this man
that's a great joke once again aunt
Colin forgets to pick up the microphone
second he picks up his tea and talks
into it at this time my daughter was uh
when I bought it the books yeah about
that I didn't know his game was talking
about download means in Atlanta and I
bought her these [ __ ] books and she
liked to read all the time she literally
could not put down this [ __ ] book and
I was like what the [ __ ] is in this book
they just said it was good on the radio
I picked up that because I her holy [ __ ]
are you and the fifth grade renewed and
I was like she's gay and he just started
you knew that well you she didn't say
she was gay because she knew I didn't
like gay women's at the time and I
realized a lot of time what you don't
like your child will bring home when she
went out to college she lost her [ __ ]
mind because she could just eat
everybody and she didn't have a mama
shoulder
she reversed her for her college 20 was
[ __ ] yeah her major was eating
everybody on campus and so I had to pull
out because we just eating everybody
right she for one thing you don't hey
well you were in jail for a year does
that really go on in the women's jails -
oh yeah oh my they eat my pudding y'all
dude it was it was crazy and nobody
wanted me cuz my I didn't call my head
and I was made out of time and I jus
just was not eating me I did that
intentional cuz you didn't want that
kind of attention I'm not attracted to
women I see not I mean I do what you do
but I prefer the help that jim brewers
want sighs she points to Jim's penis
bshorts not in the back though but I
prefer to have that sure in the front no
I just I wasn't attracted to it they
don't force each other in women's gels
do they that's more of a men's prison
thing I don't know nobody tried to force
me I mean I don't think so
well you can't speak for everybody but
no I tell you my roommate was a
hermaphrodite and it was the most porcha
me for three years well why do you think
I realize you're nervous cuz it's a
black woman
it's unfair that's also not true why do
you think I just asked her to make fun
of her I know she meant I mean do you
think I'm from clarity yeah two words oh
okay yeah my daughter dated him off at
night one time my daughter would eat any
[ __ ] thing
somehow she take them [ __ ] out and go
to work like she had a buffet fake teeth
well she lost him from eating Medicaid I
mean brutally Medicaid [ __ ] so then we
got a teeth fix but um Medicaid [ __ ]
yeah he's so bad at rots your teeth I
don't know how she she was dating on my
date yes that was a creature double
feature
[Laughter]
yeah gamera vs. Moffat I know she told I
asked um I feel like these questions I
was like so I said did you have a penis
and she was like yes what happened to
your boss she told me it was just
hanging in our stomach I think he saw
you sucking balls and English we need to
talk yeah she loves being gay she loves
it yeah she is cheap I'm happy for two
hours and she's not that I look big
little put my daughter straight we'll
eat the [ __ ] out your daughter sir
that's good to know I don't have a
daughter right but yes
don't anybody daughter but it's always
good when somebody finds their passion
in life yeah that's my passion too right
guys Oh mr. Graham Pacey about miss pett
lesbian daughter Brewer you have kids do
you notice anything about their I mean
how old are your kids nineteen sixteen
thirteen oh so you'd know I mean you'd
know by now there's no I know right now
my young Swan I was suspect for a while
is that right yeah because she wouldn't
she she do tomboy but she shed anger
issues and up until she was about five
she would only wear jeans no shirt would
never put on girl clothes and and
insisted to be called Jackson oh all
right this is we got one if you're gonna
have three there might they're probably
gonna go on
odds are this happens yeah Denise over
here cousin they're all right yeah yeah
clearly it's not for me clearly it's not
from you this is all natural she's and
then you have that conversation with the
wife like okay let's prepare well we did
have it a boy yeah yeah we didn't matter
of fact you to point where other people
acknowledge is just a tomboy my daughter
like no Jackson and cowboy hat and
[ __ ] kids up she's and um yeah all
son she sprouted up and she was a little
she was a little chubby kid and all son
I don't know she's not Jackson anymore
right right she found why Jackson why
Jack I have that's the part we have
absolutely no clue no did you ever ask
her you know what we did eventually and
here's her bro I I know this is crazy
but we were we're on vacation somewhere
and we're at a lake or something and she
ran into a
and I'm gonna say they're both about
nine eight nine years old this is like
okay now she's really good and the boys
name was Jackson and it completely
[ __ ] her up she said wait a minute
your general I'm John I'm Jackson and I
killed it that was that that's it don't
come my name's dori [ __ ] Jackson
Jackson's dead so that's uh yeah but you
never found out who she took it from Pam
oh no I really have no clue
she's uh 13 and she said what she's
thoughts all her teeth still has our
teeth okay I could change rapidly very
soon as she meets her daughter whilst
you locked up for yes